-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actor,
you know from shows
like "Deadwood"
and the John Wick films.
He stars in "American Star,"
which is in theaters
January 26th. Let's take a look.
-You and I both know that you
haven't the slightest intention
of buying a house on the island.
Right?
-♪ I dream of heaven
and living hell ♪
♪ Till I can't take it anymore ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm too far gone
to turn around ♪
♪ Don't hurt me again, okay? ♪
-Please welcome back
to the show
the one, the only
Ian McShane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
-Welcome back, Ian!
I'm so happy to have you.
-Thank you for asking me back.
It's nice to be here.
How are you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I, uh --
we were talking backstage.
I was at the Emmys on Monday.
I had a wonderful time.
-You lost.
-I did, yeah, I mean --
-I'm not speaking to you.
-I was trying
to keep it from them.
They're gonna be heartbroken.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, you -- you had described
award shows, and it's a very --
You don't pull
your punches, Ian.
I've never known you to be...
-That's right.
-You've described them
as the most
boring [bleep] things
in the world.
-Oh, Jesus Christ.
[ Laughter ]
Well, for a start, when
you're on, if you're nominated,
they put you
on the end of a row.
-Yeah.
-So there's a camera
permanently, then you lose.
You want to say, "Get me
the [bleep] out of here."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, really.
I mean,
it's so political now.
Who knows? Next year,
they'll be showing season
three of "The Bear,"
season one of "Succession,"
and they won't know which year
they're going --
You know, this year,
'cause they all --
it's all screwed up
because of the pandemic.
So there'd be season 1
of "Deadwood" is up --
-Maybe you'll win,
finally, for "Deadwood."
-That'll be in the mistake
if I did that, too. No.
I got to go --
Golden Globes is the funniest.
I won that with Mariska Hargitay
the same year.
-Yeah. It's a good year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But that was the least --
you could sort of, you know,
mingle and people have a drink,
they can have a cigarette.
But now...
But at Emmys and all Oscars,
you're like this.
-Yeah.
-And everybody's secretly
is, like, saying,
"Oh, you won!
Congratulations.
[Bleep] [ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
Resentment abounds.
-You also don't care
for the description of someone
as a national treasure.
-Oh, God, no.
It sounds like you're dead.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And should be a tea cozy
over your head,
you know, with tea brewing,
whatever.
Well, that's
an English phrase --
"Oh, he's a national treasure,
isn't he?
And he's so lovely.
He's been around so long.
Why don't we bury him, you know?
Why not?"
[ Laughter ]
-Now, this -- this film,
"American Star," you star in it,
you produced it.
-Yep.
-And you play a hit man.
And, you know,
you also, obviously,
are a big part of
the John Wick universe,
but this is a very different
kind of hit man.
-I tell you, it goes back
to about six years ago.
I made a film with this
very gifted filmmaker,
Gonzalo López-Gallego.
We made a movie
called "Hollow Point,"
with Patrick Wilson
and John Leguizamo,
which is a sort of a --
a Western noir.
And it was really good.
But like a lot of indie --
independent movies,
got lost in the shuffle
years ago
with whatever -- distribution.
But this was --
He wanted to make a film
with me again, and so did I.
And so he created this, and
with the writer Nacho Faerna.
It took us four years,
and then we found a producer,
the Spanish producers,
and my friend Michael Elliott,
who I made a couple
of other movies with,
and we had a window of time in,
um, what, spring '22 to make it.
And we did,
and it was like five weeks
on this amazing island,
Fuerteventura.
And it's the story of a guy --
I mean, he's a hit man,
but he works for a
government agency or whatever.
He commits
his own cardinal sin.
He goes to an island,
does the job --
You know, you go in,
you do the job,
you get out -- always.
But, no, there's a little
intelligence failure,
and he's forced to stay.
And instead of getting out,
he stays.
And that's when everything
gets muddled up.
And that -- the clip you showed,
that's the great French
actress Fanny Ardant,
who was Madame Truffaut,
the widow of Monsieur Truffaut,
and was wonderful.
She came on it
for a couple of days, and, uh --
It's a -- It's a really tight
European noir movie with --
It's unexpected.
It's not --
I said I wanted to,
you know, after John Wick,
"Can I shoot somebody,
please, for a change?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, I do, but this isn't
a shoot-'em, bang-'em-up.
But there's moments of that
in here. But it's more...
-You shot in the Canary Islands.
-Yeah.
-Beautiful beach.
Do you enjoy the beach?
-I live in the beach.
I live on Venice Beach.
-Oh, interesting.
'Cause I don't like the beach.
-No?
-No.
-Well, you'd like Venice Beach
because it's not really a beach.
You can't see it half the time.
-So you're --
-It's covered in marine layer.
No, I like --
-Your favorite beach
is the one you can't see.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you can.
I'm saying --
-But you've lived
on the beach for a long time.
-Yeah, I've lived there
20 years.
But, also, I like the city.
So I go from the middle
of London, Marylebone,
to living in Venice.
-Okay.
-And we both --
My wife loves it there.
And she's American.
I mean, we love --
You know, we also live
in her hometown sometimes.
She's got
a place in Michigan.
-All right.
-And we vary. It's lovely.
-When you're
an Englishman on the beach,
do you feel like
you've escaped your fate,
that you, like, actually
got out?
-No, 'cause I don't wear
Speedos, you know.
-You don't.
-No, I don't go --
Budgie -- Budgie smugglers,
as they're called now.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what, though?
I'll tell you this.
You got the body for it, Ian.
You got the body for it.
You've had the body for it
for a long time.
-Oh, my goodness.
-We went and did some research.
In your early work, you were
often in bed, shirtless.
This is, uh...
[ Cheering ]
There we go.
There's another.
Look at Ian, you guys.
-Ooh!
-Um...
-Shocking.
-Put my glasses on,
I'll have to have a look.
-"Pussycat, Pussycat,
I Love You,"
which is weirdly
not an adult film.
[ Laughter ]
-It was the sequel
to "Pussycat, Pussycat."
And it was, uh --
Um, I was a writer
with seven mistresses.
And, uh, what was it?
Who was it? What was it?
Um, it's the most
bizarre film ever made.
I mean, the great thing was,
it was in Rome for eight weeks.
And sometimes you say, "What do
you get out of the film?"
You say, "I got
a good feeling from Rome."
[ Laughter ]
-Is that your way of saying
we shouldn't go rent it?
-No, have a look if you want!
It's quite --
It's a -- It's a --
it's a crazy, crazy movie.
One of those crazy
late '60s movies.
-Do you have to see
"Pussycat, Pussycat"
to know what's going on?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
-Do I have to see the first one?
-"Pussycat, Pu--"
You just like saying "pussycat,"
don't you?
-I do.
[ Laughter ]
-I know you do.
-I'm breaking through
a lot of walls today,
thanks to you and Renée.
I really am.
-Well, the first movie
was great --
"Pussycat, Pussycat."
Uh, what was it?
That was
Peter Sellers playing --
Remember that?
That bizarre comedy?
-You did a --
What do you call these?
Uh...
-Don't look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-This is "Cosmopolitan."
It's a centerfold.
-That was England's first...
-The first male centerfold.
-I was the first centerfold.
-All right.
So, there we go.
-1970.
-19-- Look at that.
[ Cheering ]
Now, uh, two questions.
What was your --
-That was my dog!
-That was your dog.
-Moriarty.
-That --
I'm so happy it was your dog.
-Oh, yeah, it was Moriarty.
-Yeah.
Well, it wouldn't be
somebody else's dog.
Otherwise, I'd be up --
I'd be up for some kind of
animal abuse or whatever.
-I would say if it was
someone else's dog, they
wouldn't have taken it back.
-Will you please stop.
Enough of that putting it up.
[ Laughter ]
-You seem very comfortable.
-I was very comfortable.
You know?
Yeah, absolutely.
-You had it, flaunt it.
Do you feel like Moriarty looked
at you differently after that?
-Uh, no. But I --
You know,
he looked at me differently --
We once had a party,
and I wondered where
the bowl of hash had gone,
and I found him upside down
on his back for days like that,
thinking, "Oh, my God!
The dog is, whatever, stoned
out of his mind in the garden."
[ Laughter ]
But he got over it,
like everything else.
-He got over it, yeah.
I mean, can you blame a dog
after a photo shoot like this?
He's gonna go...
-He got extra Alpo.
You've got some other things
coming up, as well.
"Ballerina," which takes place
in the John Wick universe.
-"Ballerina" --
that's the --
that's the
John Wick spin-off with Ana,
the lovely Ana de Armas.
-Fantastic.
-Yeah. That's, uh --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, uh -- And then we got
"Kung Fu Panda 4".
-"Kung Fu Panda 4."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You've talked a little bit
about, um, a motivation.
And somehow, as an actor,
you have motivation,
and you try to find
a motivation for the role.
What is your motivation
for Snow Leopard
in "Kung Fu Panda 4"?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
-So, uh,
he's looking for the check
constantly across his lonely
trek across the snow.
[ Laughter ]
"Where's the check?!"
As it always is.
Just a different location.
-Well, that's a great message
for the kids.
You guys...
[ Laughter ]
Ian McShane, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No one else like him!
"American Star" is in theaters
January 26th.
We'll be right back
with music from Black Pumas.